i was actually recommending like my so
my japanese uh tutor yeah she's a
japanese woman
and she'd like takes my anime
recommendations it's like gospel
so i've seen your first mistake i've
slowly been recommending her like worse
and worse anime
and she's been like she started off
really into it yeah because i wanted to
see how much she'd lie to me
yeah because i told her to watch the
future diary because i don't know why it
came out
yeah watch it watch it right i don't
particularly like it yeah i don't think
anyone over the age of 12 can like no
it's very weird and so she watched it
and she was like yeah it was good
it was good i need to think of another
one
i i recommended rent a girlfriend to her
but i'm sure she'll be no you got to
recommend her something that's similar
to that
but just worse what's worse recommend
like heavy object
i haven't even [ __ ] because that's
made by the same person as miranicki but
it's
a million times worse i haven't watched
that oh it's so bad
it's so bad i'm gonna recommend you've
got to watch it you're going to
recommend
next uh higarashi but in dubs i'm gonna
wreck it
no no no no no you have to watch it
dubbed it's so much fun that's one
that's way better than that
actually yeah yeah yeah like the actual
like when they cried yeah yeah oh my god
i recently re-watched the i watched it i
saw i watched higurashi dab because
back when i never watched saab right
because i was like no no i have to watch
it
subtitles yeah i used to watch it on a
website called watch cartoons online oh
my god i remember that website yeah yeah
yeah
yeah throwback thursday and i always
used to like what you mean there's no
dub like because
i i refuse to watch attack on titan for
a while because this is when i just got
into anime like i don't wanna read
yeah [ __ ] read even though i've been
watching i've watched every single
[ __ ] film that jet li was in
with subtitles i don't know why i drew
the line with every jackie chan movie
yeah i i'd gone through like all of
jetly and donnie yen and jackie chan's
filmography
because i [ __ ] love them um yeah but
uh
[ __ ] what was i saying meleen [ __ ]
distracted me
you're talking about yeah i watched
higarashi because [ __ ] glass
reflection recommended it yeah
and i was like cool i'll watch it i
didn't watch the full video because i
didn't want to watch the review yeah
later on in the video i think he says
don't watch it dubbed it's [ __ ]
terrible i think
and i was like well that would have been
nice to know because i watched this
thing and i'm like what the [ __ ] this is
awful why is it called when they cry
i've never actually seen it
oh it's terrible i think there's
one good voice actress in the entire
thing and she she she stands up so much
she's carrying away which character i
think is she on oh okay
it's it's it's like the [ __ ] like the
one teammate on league who isn't feeding
it's like
please just group just do it please i
can do it oh now i need to watch it it's
it's
i love watching horrible i really wish
that the license was in limbo for the
dubs
yeah you could just watch it live on
twitch no problems because i would love
to do like a we all watch higarashi live
oh yeah
that'd be so funny that'd be amazing oh
my god
but yeah higurashu dubs sucks oh it's
okay because the new one's coming out
soon
so yeah the remake which i'm honestly
excited for
it seems like there's a lot i mean
you've done your seasonal video already
yeah there seems to be like it seems to
be getting back on track on the
just amount of anime that's just coming
full circle like just redo all the good
[ __ ] just
i mean i mean they did it with fruits
basket and they [ __ ] nailed that i
mean
they're kind of like doing the hollywood
thing now right i hope it doesn't get to
the point where
this is remake everything yeah i really
hope i don't mind the remakes i really
hope it doesn't get to the point where
one third of the season is just remakes
because i'm gonna be like ah
well remember uh like the on the trip
that we just came back from and we're in
the hotel room
and they had remade the first episode of
detective conan yeah
i remember that so we're we were sitting
in a hotel and there was this
we we turned on the tv and lo and behold
there was anime on the tv and people are
just like they're sending me on the tv
without subtitles how do i watch this
without subtitles
so it was an episode of detective conan
and it was like obviously new animation
right and we
we don't religiously follow detail
detective conan yeah yeah so
we watched it i'm like oh this must be
the new episode yeah and i'm like but
then the more we watched it we were like
wait hold on
i know what's going to happen next yeah
this is the first episode
i just felt like subaru at that point
i'm like i know what's gonna happen he's
going to kick that globe just watch him
kick the glove and then
joey's like nah this isn't the first
episode this is like new animations like
watch him kick the kick the globe he
kicked the globe and then and then we
at that point didn't realize but then it
was just a remake joey started doing
this like mad rain man thing
where he started like joey was like all
right and then this is gonna happen yeah
they're like they're gonna get in the
roller coaster like exact things i'm
like joey this is just [ __ ] weird
they're gonna get into the tunnel he's
gonna get the water go on his cheek
they're gonna come out the head's gonna
be the camera
it was like the pro cd video where he
just recites all the peter pan or
something
we were like we were just sitting there
[ __ ] drinking
like joey stop trying to [ __ ] talk i
don't know why
i don't know it's not that i don't even
like the taste of conor that much but
for some reason that first episode just
sticks
in my mind so [ __ ] much i surprised
myself i was like oh well i actually got
that right
i am before the comments accusing joey
of being a high-functioning autistic
no with detective conan episode 1 i am a
artist i high-functioning exactly what
happens with everything
i know because you saw i knew exactly
what happened like
it was worrying and i hadn't seen that
first episode in over 10 years
so i surprised myself joey joey with one
beer fully unlocks his brain
so using 100 of my brain